From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Emanuele Berry, filling in for Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》。我是 Emanuele Berry，代班 Ira Glass。
OK, school is back. Come with me now. We're going to Tempe, Arizona.
好了，开学了。跟我走吧。我们要去亚利桑那州的坦佩市。
Hello, guys. Can I have your attention? Guys, guys, guys.
嘿，各位。能注意听一下吗？各位，各位，各位。
Arizona State University has set up everything you can think of-- karaoke, scavenger hunts, ax throwing, a mechanical bull-- to help new students meet each other and make friends.
亚利桑那州立大学准备了你能想到的所有活动——卡拉 OK、寻宝游戏、投掷斧头、机械牛——来帮助新生们相互认识，结交朋友。
Are you guys ready to rumble?
你们准备好嗨起来了吗？
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼]
This is international student orientation. There are almost 400 new students here from India, China, and lots of other countries who arrived here alone, looking for any excuse to make a connection. Like, these two uncomfortable-looking guys, Nyle and Saud.
这是国际留学生迎新会。这里有近 400 名来自印度、中国和其他许多国家的新生，他们独自来到这里，都在寻找任何能建立联系的机会。比如这两个看起来不太自在的家伙，Nyle 和 Saud。
One wears an ASU cap. The other has stylish black glasses. They both have braces. They talk to my coworker Miki Meek.
一个戴着 ASU 的棒球帽。另一个戴着时尚的黑框眼镜。他们都戴着牙套。他们正在和我同事 Miki Meek 交谈。
We just met right now.
我们刚刚才认识。
You guys just met--
你们是刚认识的——
Yeah, we just met right now. We clicked.
是的，我们刚认识。我们一见如故。
What made you guys click?
是什么让你们一见如故？
Well, he was standing there alone. I was standing there alone. So I was thinking, I'm like, should I go? Should I not?
嗯，他当时一个人站在那儿。我也一个人站在那儿。我就在想，我在想，我该过去吗？还是不该过去？
Is it hard to make yourself go up and say hi?
主动走过去打招呼很难吗？
Yeah, a bit. But then I decided to. Yeah. So I just went up there. I just said hi, asked him what his major was.
是啊，有点难。但我还是决定过去。对，所以我直接走过去了。我就打了声招呼，问问他学什么专业。
Did you feel any relief when he came up and said hi?
当他走过来打招呼时，你感到如释重负吗？
Yeah, of course. There's a thing that I really don't like about myself that I don't really greet people or approach people. I need people to approach me. But at the same time, I really want to meet new people, but I don't know how to do that.
当然。我身上有一个我真的很不喜欢的特质，就是我不怎么主动问候别人或接近别人。我需要别人主动接近我。但同时，我真的很想结识新朋友，但我不知道该怎么做。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Over 1 million students from all around the world study in the United States. ASU has over 14,000. Standing near the mechanical bull is Anushka and her newly-made friend Krisha, both from India, both computer science majors.
全美有超过 100 万来自世界各地的学生。亚利桑那州立大学就有超过 14,000 名。站在机械牛旁边的 Anushka 和她刚结识的朋友 Krisha，她们都来自印度，都是计算机专业。
How many friends do you think you've made today?
你觉得你今天结识了多少个朋友？
So probably my Instagram is increased for 100 followers or something today.
大概我的 Instagram 涨了 100 个粉丝左右吧。
How about you? How many friends have you made today, do you feel like?
你呢？你觉得你今天交到多少朋友了？
I believe 10, 15, 20. I'm giving, like, a rough idea. Bro, you guys are saying 100. At least I'm giving a reasonable number.
我觉得 10 个、15 个、20 个吧。我只是大概估计一下。兄弟，你们张口就说 100 个。至少我给的是个合理的数字。
Anushka is having a great time, but there is someone she was hoping to meet here who is not here, her roommate, whose visa was rejected just two weeks before school started. They made a bunch of plans.
Anushka 玩得很开心，但她原本希望能在这里见到一个人，却没能见到，那是她的室友。在开学前两周，她的签证被拒了。她们原本计划好了一切。
Making friends together and figuring out which clubs to join, I think that was our initial plan. Probably hiking and some sports kind of stuff. I'm a hockey player, so, yeah.
一起交朋友，一起研究参加什么社团，我想这本来是我们的计划。可能还有徒步旅行和一些体育活动什么的。我是个曲棍球手，所以，是的。
Does she know why her visa got rejected?
她知道为什么签证被拒吗？
I honestly don't know.
老实说，我不知道。
People are not that comfortable sharing why their visa got rejected. Because it could be a very personal reason-- something that's Instagram, something foolish being found out because they're screening everything. So if you have your Instagram four years back, you're just joining high school, you must have put something foolish on it that they did not like. So it could be that.
人们不太愿意分享签证被拒的原因。因为这可能涉及非常个人的原因——也许是 Instagram，或者是被查出了一些愚蠢的事情，因为他们会审查一切。所以如果你四年前的 Instagram 上，也就是你刚上高中的时候，发过一些他们不喜欢的愚蠢内容，那就有可能是这个原因。
Krisha also had a friend whose visa was rejected. In fact, it was a person she went to for advice on her own student visa interview. She met him on an online ASU forum.
Krisha 也有一个朋友签证被拒了。事实上，那个人还是她自己在申请学生签证面试时咨询过的人。她是在亚利桑那州立大学的一个在线论坛上认识他的。
My friend got rejected, so I was kind of bummed because I knew him, and we had talked for a very long time, so we got along. So him not coming, I was kind of bummed. And his visa getting rejected was kind of a shocking thing for me.
我朋友被拒签了，所以我有点沮丧，因为我认识他，我们聊了很久，所以我们很合得来。他没能来，我有点难过。而且他的签证被拒让我感到很震惊。
I was already in US in my mind.
我在心里已经在美国了。
This is her friend Karthik. That's not his real name. He talked to me from India.
这是她的朋友 Karthik。这不是他的真名。他从印度和我通话。
Everything was done. I had my flight booked. I had my offer letter. I had my scholarship. I had my fund sorted. I was already in US in my mind.
一切都准备好了。机票订好了。录取通知书拿到了。奖学金拿到了。资金也准备好了。我在心里已经在美国了。
Karthik had really planned out his life at ASU. He chose the school because they had one of the few programs specifically for fintech in the country. He'd picked out his dorm room. He knew which clubs he wanted to join, what road trips he wanted to take. He wanted to go to LA. He'd even researched where he was going to eat, picked out an Indian restaurant called Dhaba that he decided would be his go-to.
Karthik 确实规划好了他在亚利桑那州立大学的生活。他选择这所学校是因为他们拥有全国为数不多的金融科技专业。他选好了宿舍。他知道想参加什么社团，想去哪儿公路旅行。他想去洛杉矶。他甚至研究过在哪儿吃饭，选定了一家叫 Dhaba 的印度餐馆，打算把它当作自己的定点食堂。
And it looked tasty.
看起来很好吃。
What he didn't account for was a shift in policy by the Trump administration, which wants fewer foreign students coming to the United States. So this year, there are stricter screenings, more visa rejections.
他没考虑到的是特朗普政府政策的转变，政府希望减少外国学生进入美国。因此今年有更严格的审查，更多的拒签。
Estimates are 150,000 fewer student visas will be approved. When Karthik went to the US embassy for his visa interview, he saw this play out. He waited in a long line for hours, dressed in a light blue button down shirt, suit jacket and trousers. His research showed that you were supposed to dress up. Finally, he almost reached the interview window.
据估计，获批的学生签证将减少 15 万份。当 Karthik 去美国大使馆参加签证面试时，他目睹了这一切。他穿着淡蓝色扣领衬衫、西装外套和长裤，在长队里排了几个小时。他的调研显示面试时应该穿得正式点。最后，他终于快到面试窗口了。
I had five guys in front of me, and I can hear everyone. I can hear them. The visa officer was a lady, and she rejected all five of them. Under two minutes, she did five rejections in two minutes.
我前面有五个人，我能听到每个人的情况。我能听到。签证官是一位女士，她拒签了前面所有的五个人。不到两分钟，她在两分钟内拒了五个人。
Wait, under two minutes, under two minutes, five people--
等等，两分钟内，两分钟内，五个人——
In two minutes.
在两分钟内。
--she's like rejection, rejection, rejection, rejection.
——她说拒签、拒签、拒签、拒签、拒签。
Yes.
是的。
And of course, when he got to the window, she rejected him, handed him a slip of paper, sent him on his way. Karthik had to scramble to try and enroll quickly in a school in India.
当然，当他走到窗口时，她拒签了他，递给他一张纸条，把他打发走了。Karthik 只好手忙脚乱地尝试在印度的一所学校快速入学。
He really didn't understand why he was rejected. He knew lots of kids got rejected each year, but he thought he was the perfect candidate. He had good grades. He had bank statements that show that he had money to cover his expenses for all four years. And he planned to return to India to run his dad's business. They want proof that you're likely to return home after study.
他真的不明白为什么被拒。他知道每年有很多孩子被拒，但他认为自己是完美的人选。他成绩优异。银行存款证明显示他有足够的钱支付四年的费用。他计划学成回国经营父亲的生意。他们想要证明你在学业完成后会回国的证据。
His rejection-- it just didn't make sense. He's not alone. Things are different on college campuses this year. And it's not just for international students. So many things about college have been upended by a wave of executive orders and lawsuits by the Trump administration. The rules have changed.
他的拒签——简直说不通。他不是一个人。今年大学校园里的情况有所不同。而且这不仅仅针对国际学生。关于大学的许多事情都被特朗普政府的一系列行政命令和诉讼颠覆了。规则改变了。
In a matter of months, there have been grant suspensions, frozen research projects and funding, DEI bans, accreditation overhauls, hundreds of millions of dollars of settlements with Ivy League schools, and personal battles that have ousted university presidents. Today on our show, we'll hear from people all trying to find their footing right now, puzzling out what's OK and what's not. Stay with us.
在短短几个月内，出现了拨款暂停、研究项目和资金冻结、多元化、公平与包容（DEI）禁令、认证体系的大修、与常春藤盟校数亿美元的赔偿协议，以及导致大学校长被撤职的个人斗争。今天在我们的节目中，我们将听听那些正试图寻找立足点的人们的故事，弄清楚什么是允许的，什么是不允许的。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Today's show-- College Disorientation. But before we get started with our first act, there is one thing that I want to note. Today's episode is about college campuses. And this week, there was some big news from a college campus.
这里是《美国生活》。今天的节目——大学定向障碍。但在开始第一幕之前，有一件事我想说明。今天的节目关于大学校园。本周，大学校园里发生了一些重大新闻。
Charlie Kirk, a founder of Turning Point USA, was shot and killed. Kirk was a key voice in pushing for a lot of policies and directives rolling out at colleges and universities right now. We've been working on this episode for months. It's not about Turning Point USA or anything related to what happened this week.
Turning Point USA 的创始人查理·柯克（Charlie Kirk）被枪杀。柯克是推动目前在各大高校推行的许多政策和指令的关键人物。我们制作这集节目已经好几个月了。它与 Turning Point USA 或本周发生的任何相关事件无关。
OK, so for the first act of our show, we're going to follow one student into college, a girl named Nevaeh Parker in Utah. This story takes place at the University of Utah, not to be confused with Utah Valley University, where Charlie Kirk was shot and killed. This story predates all that. I started following Nevaeh a year ago. This is act one of our show.
好了，在节目的第一幕，我们将跟随一名学生进入大学，她叫 Nevaeh Parker，在犹他州。这个故事发生在犹他大学，不要与查理·柯克被枪杀的犹他谷大学混淆。这个故事发生在那一切之前。我从一年前开始追踪 Nevaeh。这是节目的第一幕。
Act One, My Black President. I want to tell you about what happened when Nevaeh went to college because I think it shows what this new college landscape might look like. But first, a little bit about who she was before.
第一幕，我的黑人主席。我想告诉你们 Nevaeh 上大学时发生了什么，因为我认为这展示了新的大学环境可能是什么样子的。但首先，介绍一下她以前是个什么样的人。
From a young age, Nevaeh has been the type of person to see a problem and say, we can fix that. Not just we can fix that, but I can fix that. I'll take that on.
从小，Nevaeh 就是那种看到问题就会说“我们可以解决它”的人。不仅是“我们可以解决它”，而是“我可以解决它”。我会承担下来。
When she was 14 years old, she went to her first protest. George Floyd had just been killed. And she didn't just march. She got on stage, and she read a poem about senseless hate and speaking up. She's like, I, a 14-year-old Black girl in Utah, have the power to combat this thing.
14 岁那年，她参加了人生中第一次抗议活动。乔治·弗洛伊德刚被杀害。她不只是游行。她走上舞台，读了一首关于无谓仇恨和勇于发声的诗。她说，我，一个在犹他州的 14 岁黑人女孩，有能力对抗这件事。
In high school, Nevaeh created a Black Student Union. She wanted a BSU because she and the 10 other Black students-- Utah is pretty white-- were constantly dealing with racist BS from other students and teachers. She'd promote the clubs meetings on the morning announcements, part of her duties as student body president. Of course, she was student body president.
在高中，Nevaeh 创建了一个黑人学生联合会（BSU）。她想要一个 BSU，因为她和其他 10 名黑人学生——犹他州白人比例很高——经常要面对来自其他学生和老师的种族主义废话。她会在早间广播里宣传社团会议，这是她作为学生会主席职责的一部分。当然，她是学生会主席。
I would say it with a lot of passion, like come and join! Because people, I feel like their teachers weren't really telling them about it, and so I wanted them to know.
我会充满激情地说，比如“快来加入吧！”因为我觉得老师们并没有真正告诉大家这个组织，所以我希望他们能知道。
Do you have an announcer voice?
你有播音腔吗？
OK, wait. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Let me see. Let me see. Good morning, Royals. Welcome back to our beautiful sunny Monday. This week is filled with lots of fun activities for all of us to be a part of. The Black Student Union is going to have a meeting up in room 302. Make sure to stop by and meet friends.
好的，等等。等等，等等，等等，等等。让我试试，让我试试。早上好，Royals。欢迎回到我们美丽阳光的周一。这周充满了许多有趣的活动供我们参与。黑人学生联合会将在 302 教室举行会议。一定要来看看并结识朋友。
And that's how I started it is I was--
我就是这样开始的——
Nevaeh went to the University of Utah. She became the president of the Black Student Union, of course. And she continued to do what she'd done in high school, eagerly try and bring in new students, create a community. Here she is talking to some freshmen while tabling outside the union.
Nevaeh 进入了犹他大学。她理所当然地成为了黑人学生联合会的主席。她继续做她在高中时做过的事，热切地尝试招募新生，建立社区。这是她在联合会外摆摊时与一些新生的交谈。
Hi, you guys! How are you?
嘿，你们好！你们怎么样？
Good.
很好。
Good. What are your names?
很好。你们叫什么名字？
Zeinab.
Zeinab。
Zeinab? That's beautiful. And what's your name?
Zeinab？真好听。那你呢，你叫什么名字？
Kiara.
Kiara。
Kiara?
Kiara？
Yeah
是的。
That's so beautiful, I love that. Have you guys heard of the Black Student Union here? Yes. Period. Have you been to any of our events? OK, T. All right, so you don't need the whole spiel, but do you guys want a tote bag?
真好听，我喜欢这个名字。你们听说过这里的黑人学生联合会吗？听过。就这么简单。你们参加过我们的活动吗？好的，T。好吧，那你们就不需要我啰嗦了，但你们想要个托特包吗？
The University of Utah's a big school with over 35,000 students, but only a small number of those are Black students, barely over 1%. Black students at the University of Utah do seem to have one thing in common, which is they didn't want to go to the University of Utah.
犹他大学是一所拥有超过 35,000 名学生的大型学校，但其中黑人学生的数量很少，仅略高于 1%。在犹他大学的黑人学生似乎有一个共同点，那就是他们其实并不想来犹他大学。
I heard this from all of the Black students I talked to, including Nevaeh. They wanted to go to Howard or somewhere more diverse or just get out of Utah. But they came around on the University, in part, because of the Black Student Union.
我从所有采访过的黑人学生那里都听到了这一点，包括 Nevaeh。他们想去霍华德大学或者其他更多元化的地方，或者只是想离开犹他州。但他们最终还是选择了这所大学，部分原因是黑人学生联合会。
Nevaeh had met some of her best friends at the BSU. They had a real community on campus. It's hard to feel welcome on a predominantly white campus. I know. I went from an extremely diverse high school to a small, mostly white college to play basketball, and I struggled.
Nevaeh 在 BSU 遇到了她最好的朋友。他们在校园里有一个真正的社区。在一个以白人为主的校园里，想要感到受欢迎是很困难的。我知道。我从一所极其多元化的高中转到一所规模很小、大部分是白人的大学打篮球，我经历过挣扎。
I remember literally scanning the tiny campus as I walked to class, looking for any other Black face, and often finding none. I left that school. I never found a place where I felt like myself. When Nevaeh and the other students at the University talk about what the Black Student Union meant to them, I felt a little jealous.
我还记得自己走去上课时，在小小的校园里扫视，寻找其他黑人的面孔，却经常一无所获。我离开了那所学校。我从未找到过一个让我感到自在的地方。当 Nevaeh 和其他大学学生谈论黑人学生联合会对他们的意义时，我感到有点嫉妒。
At Utah, they had biweekly kickbacks and movie nights, study sessions, and threw big parties. And they had the Black Cultural Center, the BSU's home on campus, a literal two-story brick house. After a day of often being the only Black person in classes--
在犹他大学，他们有两周一次的聚会和电影之夜，学习小组，还举办大型派对。他们还有黑人文化中心，那是 BSU 在校园里的家，一栋真正的两层砖房。在作为课堂上唯一的黑人度过一天后——
I could literally just walk around through the back door, and I felt like I was wanted there. I feel like having Black friends at the U was really just like, OK, this is what you can hold on to. I feel like everyone there wanted to just be--
我可以径直从后门走进去，我感到自己是受欢迎的。我觉得在犹他大学有黑人朋友真的就像是，好吧，这是你可以依靠的东西。我觉得那里每个人都只是想成为——
You could just be a Black person on a college campus is kind of what you're saying?
你是说，你可以在大学校园里做一个纯粹的黑人？
Yeah, literally. Pretty much, yeah.
是的，真的。基本上是这样。
And then last year, all that changed. The state of Utah passed an anti-DEI law, meaning no more Diversity, Equity, and Inclusion at any state institutions. The law bans devoting any resources-- money, scholarships, mentoring-- to any specific identity group, like, say, a Black student organization. If public universities didn't comply, they would risk losing their funding.
然后去年，这一切都变了。犹他州通过了一项反多元化、公平与包容（Anti-DEI）法律，意味着所有州立机构不再有 DEI。该法律禁止将任何资源——资金、奖学金、指导——投入到任何特定的身份群体中，比如，黑人学生组织。如果公立大学不遵守，他们将面临失去资助的风险。
Nevaeh was president of the Black Student Union that was funded by the University. So she has to figure out what does this mean for them? Can a Black Student Union still exist under this law?
Nevaeh 是由学校资助的黑人学生联合会的主席。所以她必须弄清楚这对他们意味着什么？在这个法律下，黑人学生联合会还能存在吗？
These kinds of anti-DEI laws are reshaping college campuses across the country. Utah was ahead of most of the country. They passed their anti-DEI law a year ago. So they were figuring out how this worked before it went nationwide.
这类反 DEI 法律正在重塑全国各地的大学校园。犹他州比全国大部分地区都领先。他们在一年前通过了反 DEI 法律。所以在法律推广到全国之前，他们就已经在研究如何应对了。
And what happened with Nevaeh and the BSU is a preview of how this could play out elsewhere. So far, 28 other states have these kind of laws on the books. Earlier this year, the Trump administration sent an "End DEI" memo to all colleges and universities, saying that diversity, equity, and inclusion efforts violate civil rights laws.
而 Nevaeh 和 BSU 的遭遇预示了其他地方可能会发生什么。到目前为止，其他 28 个州也有类似的法律。今年早些时候，特朗普政府向所有高校发送了一份“结束 DEI”备忘录，称多元化、公平和包容性努力违反了民权法。
Specifically, it says DEI discriminates against white people and Asian people, and that, quote, "Educational institutions have toxically indoctrinated students with the false premise that the United States is built upon systemic and structural racism. The Department will no longer tolerate the overt and covert racial discrimination that has become widespread in this nation's educational institutions."
具体来说，它声称 DEI 歧视白人和亚裔，并称，“教育机构在毒害学生，向他们灌输美国建立在系统性和结构性种族主义基础之上的错误前提。教育部将不再容忍这种在全国教育机构中蔓延的公开和隐蔽的种族歧视。”
The new guiding principle on campuses across the country is now open to all. That phrase, "open to all," it's at the core of anti-DEI legislation. And from that perspective, the problem with a Black Student Union is it doesn't seem like it's open to all. The laws argue that by serving Black students, it's not serving other students. It's discriminating against everyone else.
全国校园里新的指导原则现在是“向所有人开放”。这句话，“向所有人开放”，是反 DEI 立法的核心。从这个角度来看，黑人学生联合会的问题在于它看起来似乎不是向所有人开放的。法律认为，服务于黑人学生，就不是在服务其他学生。这是在歧视其他人。
So what that means for universities across the country is programs are quietly disappearing. The University of Alabama at Birmingham got rid of its scholarships for Black medical students. The University of Wyoming closed down its Black Social Justice Summer Institute. Ohio University canceled its Black Alumni reunion.
因此，对全国各地的大学来说，这意味着项目正在悄悄消失。阿拉巴马大学伯明翰分校取消了黑人医学生的奖学金。怀俄明大学关闭了其黑人社会正义暑期学院。俄亥俄大学取消了黑人校友聚会。
Indiana State University dissolved its Black cultural center, so did Wright State and Texas Tech and Weber State, and the University of Cincinnati, and many more. Appalachian State University eliminated positions in the admissions office that were dedicated to Black student recruitment. Tuskegee University no longer has a program dedicated to training Black women to enter the computer science field.
印第安纳州立大学解散了其黑人文化中心，赖特州立大学、德克萨斯理工大学、韦伯州立大学和辛辛那提大学也是如此，等等。阿巴拉契亚州立大学撤销了招生办公室里致力于黑人学生招募的职位。塔斯基吉大学不再有致力于培训黑人女性进入计算机科学领域的项目。
And in Utah last fall, Nevaeh started to see the new law play out on campus.
而在去年秋天的犹他州，Nevaeh 开始看到新法律在校园里的实施。
The first big thing the University of Utah did was dissolve its Equity, Diversity, and Inclusion office. Then no more annual conference for Black high school students, no more scholarships or mentoring programs specifically for Black students. The University didn't cancel the Black Student Union, but they did start to restrict what a Black Student Union could be.
犹他大学做的第一件大事是解散了其公平、多元化和包容性办公室。随后，不再有为黑人高中生举办的年度会议，不再有专门针对黑人学生的奖学金或指导项目。大学没有解散黑人学生联合会，但他们开始限制黑人学生联合会可以做什么。
And they basically just said that every single thing would have to be ran by them. And what that meant would be that if we wanted to make any Instagram post, we would have to send it in to them. I was like, well, can we say that we don't support this bill publicly, right? No, you couldn't do any of that.
他们基本上就是说每一件事都必须由他们批准。这意味着，如果我们想发任何 Instagram 帖子，都必须先发给他们审核。我就说，好吧，那我们能公开说我们不支持这个法案吗？不行，你什么都做不了。
You can't go against the bill at all. You can't talk about anything having to do with racism. And so we were like, OK, but if we can't talk about racism or Black History, can we keep our name still? Can we still say Black Student Union? And they were like--
你完全不能反对这个法案。你不能谈论任何与种族主义有关的事情。所以我们说，好吧，但如果我们不能谈论种族主义或黑人历史，我们还能保留名字吗？我们还能叫黑人学生联合会吗？他们就——
Change it to what?
改成什么？
No, literally, that's what-- we were like, how would you change the name? And their response was basically like, we're going to have to run that by people. But like, mm, we're really going to fight for you to be able to say that. And so it's like, you can maybe just do whatever you want once they just don't hear the word Black.
不，真的，他们就是这么说的——我们要怎么改名字？他们的回应基本上是说，我们得找人商量一下。但，呃，我们要真的努力争取让你们能保留这个名字。所以这就意味着，只要他们听不到“黑人”这个词，你可能就能做任何你想做的事。
So every time Nevaeh wanted to host an event, she now had to run it by the University. And when the word Black came up to advertise those event--
所以每次 Nevaeh 想举办活动，她现在都得经过学校批准。当用于宣传活动的文案里出现“黑人”这个词时——
And they would just be like, let's think of other ways to say this so that people don't get upset, and so we don't get flagged by the University.
他们就会说，让我们想想别的表达方式，这样人们就不会感到不快，我们也不会被学校标记。
Like, say what? What's an example?
比如，说什么？举个例子？
Oh, radical. They would like to say radical joy, radical love.
哦，激进（radical）。他们喜欢说“激进的快乐”、“激进的爱”。
Radical love, radical joy instead of Black love, Black joy.
激进的爱，激进的快乐，而不是“黑人的爱”、“黑人的快乐”。
Yeah. And so they would just be like, yeah. Just do that. That's the one term I can hear her saying it, one of the staff.
对。他们就会说，就这么做。那是其中一个工作人员说的词。
What does radical joy even mean?
“激进的快乐”到底是什么意思？
[CHUCKLES] I mean, I don't really know. Honestly, I don't even know. I don't know.
[轻笑] 我意思是，我真的不知道。老实说，我甚至不知道。我不知道。
Nevaeh kept hearing that anything they did needed to be open to all, which was confusing for Nevaeh because everything the BSU did was already open to everyone. Nevaeh was like, this law is coming for us. She needed a way to save the BSU, so she made a choice.
Nevaeh 不断听到他们说任何活动都需要“向所有人开放”，这让 Nevaeh 很困惑，因为 BSU 做的所有事情本来就是向所有人开放的。Nevaeh 意识到这个法律是冲着他们来的。她需要一种方法来挽救 BSU，所以她做出了一个选择。
She thought the only way they could survive as the BSU she loved would be to become an independent organization, to separate from the University, not to be a university-sponsored club. They were going to go it alone. This meant losing all their funding, their advisor, the status they had as the official club for Black students at the University of Utah.
她认为他们要作为她所热爱的 BSU 存活下来的唯一途径就是成为一个独立组织，脱离学校，不再是学校资助的社团。他们要单干。这意味着失去所有的资金、指导老师，以及作为犹他大学官方黑人学生社团的地位。
How did it feel to finally make that choice?
最终做出这个选择感觉如何？
Terrifying, genuinely. Because I was like, if I'm making the wrong decision, it felt like it would all fall on me.
恐怖，真心话。因为我在想，如果我做了错误的决定，感觉一切责任都会落在我头上。
To run the BSU independently, they needed money. Nevaeh has to set up a GoFundMe so the BSU can do basic things. She has to figure out where they can meet.
为了独立运营 BSU，他们需要钱。Nevaeh 不得不设立 GoFundMe 来筹款，这样 BSU 才能做一些基本的事情。她得弄清楚他们能在哪儿聚会。
Before the law, one of the places they met regularly was the Black Cultural Center. But after the law, it was unstaffed and didn't have any funding. Nevaeh was told she'd have to make a reservation to book the space.
法律出台前，他们经常聚会的地方之一是黑人文化中心。但法律生效后，那里没有了工作人员，也没有了任何资金。Nevaeh 被告知她必须预约才能使用这个空间。
So we didn't really know how to book the space with the Black Cultural Center because for a couple months there, they were telling us, we're not sure if it would be free to students. So they were just basically saying, we might have to pay for it. And we were like, we can't pay for it. We don't want to pay for it. That's crazy.
所以我们真的不知道该怎么在黑人文化中心预约空间，因为那几个月里，他们一直告诉我们，不确定这对学生是否免费。所以他们基本上是说，我们可能得付费。我们当时就说，我们付不起。我们不想付钱。这太疯狂了。
And that is crazy to ask students to pay so they can gather on a campus they are already paying thousands to go to. They have their first kickback of the year in a classroom they can use for free at the Student Union. Nevaeh tries to organize events that are fun and will bring out students, but won't cost any money.
要求学生付费才能在他们已经付了数千美元学费的校园里聚会，这确实很疯狂。他们在那年第一次聚会是在学生会的一间可以免费使用的教室里进行的。Nevaeh 尽量组织既有趣又能吸引学生，但又不需要花钱的活动。
She emails the Utah Jazz to see if she can get free tickets for a BSU event. It works. They go to a game against the Heat. It's a chaotic start to the semester.
她给犹他爵士队发邮件，看能不能为 BSU 活动拿到免费门票。成功了。他们去看了对阵热火队的比赛。学期开始时一片混乱。
The club is happening. Nevaeh's life is full of tasks-- some of which she expected and some of which she really didn't. For instance, now that the club was no longer part of the University, she was fundraising to keep the BSU alive. Random people from the Salt Lake Community saw that and wanted to share their ideas for how she should run things. So now, she was also a private fundraiser, taking calls before, between, and after classes. She didn't want to miss a possible opportunity.
社团活动在继续。Nevaeh 的生活充满了任务——有些是她预料到的，有些则是她真的没想到的。例如，既然社团不再属于大学的一部分，她就得筹款以维持 BSU 的生存。盐湖城社区里的陌生人看到了这一点，想分享他们对她应该如何运作社团的想法。所以现在，她还成了一个私人筹款人，在课前、课间和课后接电话。她不想错过任何可能的机会。
One time, she got a message from a man who said he was retired and had a background in strategic planning. So she got up early before class to get on Zoom with him.
有一次，她接到一个男人的消息，说他已经退休，有战略规划背景。所以她早起去上课前和他开了 Zoom 会议。
He was in his home office, I remember. And he was this old white guy. And he was like, I just hate to see that this is happening. And he was our government has gotten really off the rails. And they're not understanding that DEI is a good thing.
我记得他在自己的家庭办公室里。他是个白人老头。他说，我真讨厌看到这种事发生。他说我们的政府已经严重偏离了轨道。他们不明白 DEI 是件好事。
And I was like, OK. We were jiving. It was great to see someone like him speak the way that he was and support us in the way that he was. And so he was like, this is what you need to do. You need to rebrand. You need to talk to this person. You need to go to the LDS Church because they have a big stake in the decisions that are made within the government.
我就说，好的。我们聊得很投机。看到像他这样的人说出那样的话，以那样的方式支持我们，真是太好了。所以他说，这是你们需要做的。你们需要重塑品牌。你们需要和这个人谈谈。你们需要去摩门教会（LDS Church），因为他们在政府决策中占有很大的话语权。
And he was like, a lot of people hated this bill. And he was like, you just need to get the LDS church on your side because they love this and this. And he's a member as well. And he was like, you can talk to them. They'll listen to you. You need to go and tell them.
他说，很多人讨厌这个法案。他说，你们只需要让 LDS 教会站在你们这边，因为他们喜欢这个，喜欢那个。他自己也是那里的成员。他说，你们可以和他们谈谈。他们会听你们的。你们需要去告诉他们。
He's like got to get out there and start lobbying, basically.
他这是让你去进行游说，基本上。
Yeah. No, genuinely. He was like, march up to the gates.
是的。不，真的。他说，直接走到大门口去。
And he mentioned to Nevaeh that he had money.
而且他还向 Nevaeh 提到他有钱。
He was like, eventually a donation would be in the future, but we need these things to happen first so that more donations can come. And I remember calling my mom and being like, I don't really know why this white guy just wanted to talk with me for an hour about BSU.
他说，未来可能会有捐款，但我们首先需要这些事情发生，这样才会有更多的捐款。我记得我给我妈打电话说，我真的不知道这个白人为什么只想跟我聊一小时关于 BSU 的事。
I'm not really sure what's going on. And she was like, is he giving you money? And I was like, I think eventually if we do what he wants us to do. I don't know.
我真的不知道怎么回事。她说，他给你钱了吗？我说，我觉得如果我们按他想要的做，以后或许会。我不知道。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
This goes nowhere. It does not lead to any donation. Nevaeh and the man never talk again. Calls like these took a lot of time, time that she didn't have.
这事儿最后没下文。并没有带来任何捐款。Nevaeh 和那个男人再也没有联系过。像这样的电话占用了大量时间，而她根本没有那么多时间。
For the first time, Nevaeh's grades, which had always been perfect, started slipping. Nevaeh started anxiety medication. She was making calculations like, do I do this thing for BSU, or do I do this thing for school? If I skip this assignment, I'll still pass this class. So it's OK, right?
第一次，Nevaeh 一直完美的成绩开始下滑。Nevaeh 开始服用焦虑症药物。她在心里做计算，比如，我该为 BSU 做这件事，还是为学业做那件事？如果我跳过这个作业，我这门课还是能及格的。所以没关系，对吧？
Before the DEI law, the work of making the BSU exist was handled by adults with full-time jobs. Last year, that adult became 19-year-old Nevaeh. Of course, Nevaeh had the support of other BSU members. They told me they really appreciated Nevaeh and that the BSU wouldn't have continued without her. But Nevaeh says people would also text her and say they were too busy or stressed to help out. Nevaeh would always respond kindly.
DEI 法律生效前，维持 BSU 运营的工作是由有全职工作的大人们处理的。去年，那个“大人”变成了 19 岁的 Nevaeh。当然，Nevaeh 得到了其他 BSU 成员的支持。他们告诉我，他们非常感激 Nevaeh，如果没有她，BSU 就不会持续下去。但 Nevaeh 说人们也会发短信给她，说他们太忙或压力太大无法帮忙。Nevaeh 总是会亲切地回应。
Please let me know if I can do anything for you. I appreciate what you've been able to do. I know this has been a hard year. That would be my response. And I just felt like I couldn't say anything else. I didn't really know what else to say because, I don't know, I wanted to beg them to stay, and I wanted to tell them that we really needed help, but it just felt like, I don't know, it felt like I couldn't do that.
“请让我知道我能为你做些什么。我很感激你能做的一切。我知道这是艰难的一年。”这就是我的回复。我觉得我没法说别的。我真的不知道还能说什么，因为，我不知道，我想求他们留下来，我想告诉他们我们真的很需要帮助，但那种感觉就是，我不知道，感觉我不能那么做。
Were there moments where you were like, I don't want to do this anymore? I can't do this anymore? Like, yeah.
有没有那一刻你想过，我不想再做了？我不能再做了？是吗？
This is so hard to answer because, [SIGHS] yes, there were many, many, many moments where I would just be like going to sleep at night and being very, very overwhelmed with the week ahead or the day, the next day, honestly. And I didn't know how to communicate how bad I was struggling mentally. And so it was kind of just this thing where I had to deal with it on my own and just keep pushing through, I guess, because that just felt like my only option.
这个问题太难回答了，因为，[叹气] 是的，有很多很多很多时刻，我会觉得晚上躺在床上，对未来的一周或明天感到非常非常不知所措。我不知道该怎么表达我在心理上挣扎得有多严重。所以这就是那种我必须自己处理，然后继续坚持下去的事，我想，因为那似乎是我唯一的选择。
The University of Utah has had a BSU since the 1960s. Students created it during the fight for civil rights. This new law had wiped out so much of what the BSU had created over seven decades. Nevaeh felt like it couldn't end with her. She felt like she was president of the only organization left to specifically support Black students at the University of Utah, and it had to keep existing.
犹他大学自 20 世纪 60 年代以来就一直有 BSU。学生们是在争取民权的斗争中创建它的。这项新法律抹去了 BSU 七十年来创造的大部分成果。Nevaeh 觉得这不能在她这一代终结。她觉得她是唯一剩下的专门支持犹他大学黑人学生的组织的主席，它必须继续存在。
Nevaeh and the BSU made it to February, Black History month, which meant skate night. Skate night was always one of the biggest events of the year. This year, Nevaeh had thrown a ton of money they'd fundraised into the event.
Nevaeh 和 BSU 坚持到了 2 月份，也就是黑人历史月，这意味着溜冰之夜。溜冰之夜一直是全年最盛大的活动之一。今年，Nevaeh 把他们筹集的大量资金投入到了这个活动中。
She bought 70 tickets at the local roller rink, and that's how many people she needed to show up for it to be a success. If they could pull this off on their own, it would feel like the BSU was still thriving on campus. So it's a Saturday night, and the event starts at midnight.
她在当地溜冰场买了 70 张票，这就是她需要出席的人数，才能让活动取得成功。如果他们能独自完成这次活动，就会感觉 BSU 在校园里依然蓬勃发展。那天是周六晚上，活动在午夜开始。
Hey, guys. It's me and Nevaeh here. We're almost at full capacity, so if you're coming with your friends, come soon.
嘿，各位。我是 Nevaeh。我们快满员了，所以如果你们要和朋友过来，快点来。
Nevaeh and her VP, Sandrine, are posting on Instagram. Neon purple lights glow in the background as they talk. The two are dressed up-- college night dressed up that is-- cute tops and jeans. Nevaeh has straightened her usually curly hair. Sandrine's is picked out. They seem giddy.
Nevaeh 和她的副主席 Sandrine 正在 Instagram 上发帖。霓虹紫色的灯光在她们身后闪烁。两人都精心打扮过——也就是那种大学之夜的打扮——可爱的上衣配牛仔裤。Nevaeh 把她通常卷曲的头发拉直了。Sandrine 的头发挑出来了。她们看起来很高兴。
Please, please, please, especially U of U students, we have a limited amount of tickets, but it's so much for so please come.
求求你们，求求你们，特别是犹他大学的学生，我们的票数有限，但真的很棒，所以请一定要来。
Immediately, it's packed. There's a line out the door. And now Nevaeh's biggest worry is that they won't have enough tickets.
很快，场馆就挤满了人。门口排起了长队。现在 Nevaeh 最担心的是票不够。
I was sitting at the front, whatever, and I was basically like, oh my goodness. I knew the check coming back was going to be thousands of dollars. I knew it because the office, too-- the people who were working-- the workers at the Classic Fun Center were being like, so you're running out of the wristbands you paid for.
我当时坐在前台，随便吧，我当时心想，噢天哪。我知道退回来的结账单将是几千美元。我知道因为办公室那边的人——那些工作人员——Classic Fun Center 的员工都在说，你们的腕带快用完了。
We're going to have to-- either you're going to have to cut people off at the door, or we're going to have to keep charging you for more people. And I was basically just like, well, I can't turn anyone away. Somehow we're going to have to just make this work. We just got to do it because people just-- this is like our big thing. And everyone was so excited about it, too. And so, I was a-- people would say maybe a pushover in that sense. And I don't regret it.
我们得——要么你们得在门口截住人，要么我们得继续按人数向你们收费。我当时心想，我不能把任何人拒之门外。不管怎样，我们必须把这事做成。我们必须做，因为大家——这是我们的大活动。每个人都对此感到非常兴奋。所以，人们可能会说我在这一点上是个容易妥协的人。我并不后悔。
The night cost them thousands of dollars, money Nevaeh had to scramble to raise, but over 300 people showed up.
那个晚上花了他们几千美元，这笔钱 Nevaeh 不得不四处筹集，但来了 300 多人。
I definitely felt like a big sense of, I guess, pride, you could say. This is a huge event. So many people are having a great time and enjoying themselves. And yeah, everyone's just happy and together, and that's what we want. That's what we want it to be.
我绝对感到了一种强烈的，我想说，骄傲感。这是一场大型活动。这么多人玩得很开心，很享受。是的，每个人都很开心，聚在一起，这就是我们想要的。这就是我们想要的样子的。
She pulled it off. She'd protected the thing that she cared about most-- a place where Black students could feel welcome. By the end of the spring semester, she'd tripled BSU membership.
她成功了。她保护了她最在乎的东西——一个让黑人学生感到受欢迎的地方。到春季学期结束时，她把 BSU 的成员人数增加了两倍。
There's something insidious about the anti-DEI laws. They present themselves as civil rights laws, while eliminating so many of the things that the civil rights movement demanded on university campuses. They present themselves as laws to promote inclusion, open to all, while disappearing all the programs and money and support that actually made Black kids feel welcome.
反 DEI 法律有一种阴险之处。它们将自己包装成民权法，同时却消灭了民权运动在大学校园里要求的许多东西。它们将自己包装成旨在促进包容、“向所有人开放”的法律，同时却抹去了所有真正让黑人孩子感到受欢迎的项目、资金和支持。
Nevaeh is constantly trying to create space for Black students. The University is literally taking space away. I watched the university do this in real time one day.
Nevaeh 不断尝试为黑人学生创造空间。大学则实际上在剥夺空间。有一天我实时目睹了大学是怎么做的。
The Black Student Union used to have a home on campus, the Black Cultural Center. It'd been one of Nevaeh's favorite places on campus. The house was still there, but the University wouldn't tell them what was going to happen with it. They just kept saying they were working on it and they'd try and reopen it. It just sat there the whole year, often locked. The old Black Cultural Center staff gone.
黑人学生联合会以前在校园里有个家，就是黑人文化中心。那曾是 Nevaeh 在校园里最喜欢的地方之一。房子还在那儿，但大学不告诉他们会发生什么。他们一直说他们在处理，会试着重新开放。那房子整年就闲置在那里，经常锁着。原来的黑人文化中心员工也不见了。
And then at the end of the school year, the University quietly renamed it. It was no longer the Black Cultural Center. It was now the Center for Community and Cultural Engagement. Nevaeh and I drove by.
学年末，学校悄悄地给它改了名。它不再是黑人文化中心。它现在是“社区与文化参与中心”。Nevaeh 和我开车路过。
Right to the left right here. Right here. So you can see that sign outside of it. Oh, the doors are open. Should we go in?
就在左边这里。就在这儿。你可以看到外面的那个牌子。噢，门开着。我们要进去吗？
Let's park. Let's park. Yeah.
停下吧。停下吧。是的。
It's a two-story brick house. When we pulled up, the door was actually propped open.
那是一栋两层砖房。我们靠近时，门居然虚掩着。
OK, so I guess first just tell me-- oh, it still says Black Cultural Center on the door.
好的，那我猜先告诉我——噢，门上还写着“黑人文化中心”。
Yes, on the door. But I think they're in the works of decorating and reassigning things. So on the door, you can see it's a-- what would it be? Like, a vinyl. Like vinyl words on the screen door. But then outside of it, the actual sign now says Center for Community and Cultural Engagement instead of Black Cultural Center. And so I guess for right now, it's a good thing that the door still says it with the vinyl lettering.
是的，门上写着。但我认为他们正在进行装饰和任务重新分配。所以你在门上可以看到，那是什么？一种乙烯基贴纸。屏风门上的乙烯基文字。但在它外面，现在的正式标牌已经写成了“社区与文化参与中心”，而不是“黑人文化中心”。所以我觉得目前来说，门上还有那个乙烯基字样算是一件好事。
OK. When did you hear that the sign was going to change, when that was going to go down?
好的。你什么时候听说牌子要换的，什么时候开始的？
We never heard anything about that. And still no one has said that. Are they renaming it now? And that's the questions I have. Because if they're changing that sign and saying that, then what does it mean for everything else inside of it?
我们从来没听说过这件事。到现在还没人说过。他们现在就要改名吗？这就是我的疑问。因为如果他们要换那个牌子，说那样的话，那房子里面的一切又意味着什么呢？
I mean, it's just like there's no communication or transparency once again. It's not like there was any public notice, like, we're so sorry to this community. We're taking away the sign, and we're replacing it. Like, we are sorry, and we wish we didn't have to do this. That would go a long way. But, OK, let's see.
我的意思是，这就像又一次没有任何沟通或透明度。不是说有什么公告，说“我们很抱歉向社区宣布，我们要撤下这个牌子，换成别的。我们很抱歉，我们希望不必这样做。”那会好很多。但，好吧，看看吧。
We open the door and walk into the house. Nevaeh seems annoyed but ready to show me around.
我们推开门走进房子。Nevaeh 看起来很恼火，但还是准备带我参观。
Knock, knock. How are you?
有人在吗？你们好？
Doing well. How are you?
挺好的。你好吗？
I'm good, thank you.
我很好，谢谢。
There's a white woman sitting behind a desk inside. She's one of the employees of the new center. Nevaeh brightly says hello to her and begins my tour.
有个白人女性坐在桌后。她是新中心的工作人员之一。Nevaeh 愉快地向她打招呼，开始带我参观。
There's a little seating area and a library of books, Black History books, a signed copy of Langston Hughes. She shows me a meeting room, a kitchen filled with snacks, a bunch of closets all over the house. In every room, there is a closet filled with BSU supplies, things like notebooks, pencils, postcards, tables, buckets of candy.
有一个小座位区和一个图书室，里面有黑人历史书籍，还有一本兰斯顿·休斯（Langston Hughes）的签名书。她带我参观了一间会议室、一间堆满零食的厨房，房子里到处都是壁橱。每个房间里都有一个装满 BSU 用品的壁橱，比如笔记本、铅笔、明信片、桌子、一桶桶糖果。
So you can see, the graduation stoles right there.
你看，毕业披肩就在那儿。
The graduation stoles are kind of like African colors.
毕业披肩看起来像是非洲色彩的。
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And then we have this sign is used for tabling. So it just like--
是的。对。还有这个牌子是用来摆摊的。所以它只是——
Nevaeh was excited and proud to show me around, but I have to admit it was also kind of eerie. So much of it is exactly as Nevaeh remembered it. Even the former director of the BCC's name is still painted above his office door.
Nevaeh 在带我参观时显得既兴奋又自豪，但我不得不承认这也让人感到有些诡异。这里的一切大部分都和 Nevaeh 记忆中的一模一样。甚至连原来的中心主任的名字还漆在他的办公室门上。
Because that's the most public place--
因为那是这里最公共的地方——
It feels like a tour of the house you moved out of or the house you grew up in, where you kind of still know where the stuff is.
感觉像是参观你搬出的房子，或者你长大的房子，你还隐约记得东西在哪儿。
Yeah, but it's also somehow not like in your full-- [SIGHS] It's not fully in your hands. I don't know. It's weird, but is a part of our stuff.
是的，但它同时也莫名其妙地不再完全在你的——[叹气] 它不再完全在你的掌控之下了。我不知道。这很怪，但这也是我们的东西的一部分。
We end the tour at a beautiful mural by the entrance. It's a big white sankofa bird with an African tribal pattern behind it. And then in big block letters next to it, it says, The University of Utah's Black Cultural Center.
我们以门口的一幅美丽壁画结束了参观。那是一只巨大的白色萨卡拉（Sankofa）鸟，背景带有非洲部落图案。旁边用巨大的方块字写着：“犹他大学黑人文化中心”。
But I mean, yeah, I mean, it's interesting. Actually, now that I'm just pointing it out to you, yeah, the signs are still there. Yeah.
但我的意思是，是的，很有趣。其实，既然我现在指出来给你看，是的，标志还在。是的。
It was because we did not know what was going to happen.
那是因为我们当时不知道会发生什么。
The staffer at the desk interrupts Nevaeh's tour to explain the sign change.
台后的工作人员打断了 Nevaeh 的参观，解释了更名的事。
With all of the bills and stuff, we're hoping that we could still keep this name The Black Cultural Center, but we're going to have to change it.
因为所有的法案什么的，我们曾希望还能保留“黑人文化中心”这个名字，但我们不得不改掉。
So it is confirmed. Yeah, I saw the sign outside.
所以确定了。是的，我在外面看到了招牌。
Yes.
是的。
And I was like, huh? So when was that decided? Like, recent?
我心想，哈？那是什么时候决定的？最近吗？
Kind of, but yeah. It was a few months ago that it was decided that we do need to change it. And then we just haven't gotten around to it because there's still even more changes. And so the CCCE will be taking over this building fully.
算是吧。几个月前决定确实需要改名的。然后我们一直没顾得上，因为还有更多的变化。所以社区与文化参与中心（CCCE）将完全接管这栋楼。
OK.
好的。
So this will be like for BSU to use a lot, too, and just everything else. But we're still going to keep a lot of what's on the inside, but we do have to change the name.
所以这里以后也会有很多给 BSU 使用的机会，以及其他用途。但我们依然会保留大部分内部的装饰，但名字确实得改。
Like officially, like, in Google Maps and stuff?
像正式地，在谷歌地图之类的地方也要改吗？
I don't know how all of that's going to play out.
我不知道那一切会怎么运作。
But it'll change?
但肯定会改？
It will change.
会改的。
Do about the decorations on the inside? Is that going to have to be covered up?
那里面的装饰呢？那些也得被盖住吗？
Nevaeh points to the mural with the bird and the words Black Cultural Center.
Nevaeh 指着那幅有鸟和“黑人文化中心”字样的壁画。
This might have to go. We're not quite sure about--
这个可能得去掉。我们还不确定——
No, that's OK. Thank you. No, yeah. I just have-- is it because it says Black? That's why. OK, that's what I thought.
不，没关系。谢谢。不，是的。我只是想问——是因为它写着“黑人”吗？这就是原因。好的，我也这么想。
We can't even use the word inclusive. Yeah we can't say that this is just for Black students so-- because you know, we have to be inclusive without saying inclusive.
我们甚至不能用“包容”这个词。是的，我们不能说这是专为黑人学生服务的，所以——因为你知道，我们必须在不使用“包容”这个词的前提下表现出包容。
OK. Yeah, no, it's very sad. It's very sad to me.
好的。是的，不，这太可悲了。对我来说这太可悲了。
Nevaeh thanks the woman for her honesty, and we start to head out.
Nevaeh 感谢那位女士的坦诚，我们开始离开。
I appreciate it.
谢谢。
You take care, Nevaeh.
保重，Nevaeh。
You, too.
你也是。
Oh, man, how are you feeling?
天哪，你感觉怎么样？
I'm going to cry. This is horrible. This is actually, actually horrible.
我要哭了。这太可怕了。这真是，真是太可怕了。
What about that pushed you over the edge?
是什么让你崩溃了？
They're officially changing the name, which I didn't think was going to happen, officially. I don't know. That's crazy.
他们正式要改名字了，我本来以为那不会发生，正式地。我不知道。这太疯狂了。
You're really upset, are you?
你真的很难过，是吗？
Yeah. No, I am really upset. And I don't want to take it out on her because clearly it's not her fault, but what is going on? Actually, what's going on?
是的。不，我真的很生气。我不想把气撒在她身上，因为显然不是她的错，但到底发生了什么？实际上，到底发生了什么？
And why didn't they think tell us? And then she said it would be for the Black Student Union to use. If we don't even know, your plans-- sorry.
为什么他们没想过告诉我们？她说以后还会让黑人学生联合会使用。如果我们连你们未来的计划都不知道——抱歉。
No, you're good.
不，没事。
If don't even know your future plans for it, how are we supposed to know that we're welcome there. How are we supposed to think, oh yeah, we're going to be fine when they don't even communicate any of that to us?
如果我们连你们未来的计划都不知道，我们怎么可能知道我们还受不受欢迎？我们怎么可能认为，哦，是的，我们以后会好好的，当他们甚至不沟通任何这一切时？
And it's not like they don't have my contact. They do. They can ask me to do other things. They can let us know about this. And it's just very frustrating and sad to me.
并不是他们没有我的联系方式。他们有。他们可以让我做别的事。他们可以让我们知道这个消息。这对我来说真的很令人沮丧和难过。
It's like the sign out front, you're like, OK, it seems like they're changing it, but now it just feels like it's official, official?
就像外面的牌子，你会觉得，哦，看起来他们好像要改了，但现在感觉是“正式”要改了？
Yeah. Yeah, it does feel official now that she just confirmed that they for sure are changing it. And it just comes back like it just to the exact thing I was talking about, like, the word Black being so weaponized. It is so incredibly weaponized, and that just it blows my mind how-- I don't know. I just wish that maybe their team or something would have just said no.
是的。是的，她证实了他们肯定要改名，现在感觉确实是正式的了。这就又回到了我刚才说的，把“黑人”这个词当作武器。它被极度武器化了，这让我非常震惊——我不知道。我只是希望也许他们的团队什么的能直接说“不”。
What if they just said no? What if they just said, no, we're not changing the name? What would happen then? Would they fire everyone? I don't know. I just feel like now, what do we have to lose? Because now we're losing this, officially.
如果他们直接说“不”呢？如果他们说，不，我们不会改名字？那会发生什么？他们会解雇所有人吗？我不知道。我只是觉得现在，我们还有什么可失去的呢？因为现在，我们要正式失去这个了。
It's not just a talk. It's not just a fear. It's actually happening. And if they're changing the stuff on the inside, too, then it's like, absolutely you're erasing-- you're absolutely erasing the Center. I don't know. I'm actually in shock, kind of like. Is it real? Is this real life right now because it just feels very dystopian to me. [FRUSTRATED SIGH]
这不再只是说说而已。这不再只是恐惧。它正在发生。如果他们连里面的东西也要改，那这就是在抹杀——绝对是在抹杀这个中心。我不知道。我其实处于震惊之中。这是真的吗？这现在是现实生活吗？因为它对我来说太反乌托邦了。[沮丧的叹息]
Nevaeh is no longer the high school kid making chipper morning announcements. Nevaeh's only 20. She was three years old when Obama was elected president, came of age in the era of Black Squares and Black Lives Matter protest.
Nevaeh 不再是那个在高中心情愉快地做广播的孩子了。Nevaeh 才 20 岁。奥巴马当选总统时她才 3 岁，她在“黑方块”和“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动时代成长。
In her mind, the country was shifting to a more accepting place. And where we are now, the world she's navigating it's so different than the one she grew up believing in. I talked with the University about the sign change. They said Black gives the impression that the center isn't open to all.
在她看来，国家正在向一个更包容的地方转变。而我们现在所处的现实，她正在应对的世界，与她成长过程中所相信的世界完全不同。我与大学谈到了改名的事。他们说“黑人”给人一种中心不向所有人开放的印象。
So I asked, can you say the word Black? They said, it depends. If it's cultural, educational, yes. If it's tied to resources, no. They said they had to be careful. They run all their events like Pride Week, Women's Week, Black anything by lawyers.
所以我问，你们能用“黑人”这个词吗？他们说，视情况而定。如果是文化、教育层面，可以。如果是和资源挂钩，不行。他们说必须谨慎。他们把所有的活动，比如骄傲周、女性周、“黑人”相关的任何活动，都交给律师审核。
I just want to say one more thing about the word Black. It's just a word. Who cares? But it's not. It's a word that was decided on by Black people. There's a long list of shitty and degrading words that white people have lodged at us, enslaved and murdered us for. Black is the word we got to add to the list, the one that we got to choose, capital B Black.
关于“黑人”这个词，我还想多说一句。这只是一个词。谁在乎呢？但事实并非如此。这是一个由黑人自己决定的词。有一长串白人强加给我们的、低劣且贬损的词汇，他们为了这些词奴役和杀害我们。“黑人”是我们得到的可以加到列表上的词，我们能够选择的一个词，大写的“B”开头——黑人（Black）。
We are Black. It's very-- call us by our name. Removing Black, taking that off the list of acceptable words as a way of saying you don't decide, we do.
我们是黑人。这非常——请叫我们的名字。移除“黑人”，把它从可接受的词汇列表中剔除，这是一种表达——“你不决定，由我们决定”的方式。
Nevaeh, though, she refuses to be erased. Even after that terrible year with the anti-DEI law, Nevaeh is still pushing forward, still determined to keep the Black Student Union alive. She just started her junior year. On the first day of school, she's outside tabling for the BSU. A young woman approaches. She's a transfer student from Oregon.
然而，Nevaeh 拒绝被抹去。即使在反 DEI 法律那可怕的一年后，Nevaeh 依然勇往直前，决心让黑人学生联合会活下去。她刚开始大三。开学第一天，她正在外摆摊宣传 BSU。一个年轻女子走了过来。她是来自俄勒冈州的转校生。
Hi, you guys! What is your name?
嘿，你们好！你们叫什么名字？
I'm Deja.
我是 Deja。
Deja, you're beautiful.
Deja，你真漂亮。
Thank you.
谢谢。
It's so nice to meet you. My name is Nevaeh, and we're the Black Student Union here. Have you heard about us? Or have you-- no? OK, well, you should totally join.
很高兴认识你。我叫 Nevaeh，我们是这里的黑人学生联合会。你听说过我们吗？或者你——没有？好的，那你一定要加入。
This is our Instagram right here. So if you just want to join our Instagram. Right now, we're just working on increasing, like our engagement and our presence on campus. After some things happened last year with the legislature, we got some of our funding taken away. But now, we have a fully functioning e-board, and we're going to do a lot of events this year. So I want you guys--
这是我们的 Instagram。如果你想关注我们的 Instagram 的话。目前，我们只是在致力于增加参与度和我们在校园的存在感。去年立法机构发生了一些事情后，我们失去了一些资助。但现在，我们有一个功能齐全的执行委员会，今年我们要举办很多活动。所以我希望你们——
In this post-DEI era, I think on a lot of campuses how welcome you are as a Black student-- the difference between feeling like you belong or don't belong-- will depend on if you have a Nevaeh or not.
在这个后 DEI 时代，我认为在许多校园里，作为黑人学生你有多受欢迎——归属感与否的差异——将取决于你是否有像 Nevaeh 这样的人。
Miki Meek reported this story with me, additional editing from Robyn Semien.
Miki Meek 与我共同报道了这个故事，Robyn Semien 进行了补充编辑。
Coming up, since he's away and I'm hosting, we're going to talk about Ira for 15 minutes. That's after the break from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，既然他不在，而我来主持，我们要谈论 Ira 15 分钟。那是芝加哥公共广播电台节目中场休息之后的内容。
It's This American Life. I'm Emanuele Berry, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, College Disorientation. In this hour, we're looking at some of the dramatic shifts in higher education, a flood of executive orders and memos from the Trump administration. Let me just run down a few of the new directives for America's colleges and universities.
这里是《美国生活》。我是 Emanuele Berry，代班 Ira Glass。今天的节目，大学定向障碍。在这一个小时里，我们来看看高等教育中的一些戏剧性转变，以及来自特朗普政府的一波行政命令和备忘录。让我梳理一下美国高校的一些新指令。
There was a January executive order called Ending Radical and Wasteful Government DEI Programs and Preferencing, the Dear Colleague letter in February. March, a new task force starts to investigate DEI and antisemitism.
1 月份有一项名为“结束激进和浪费的政府 DEI 项目及偏向”的行政命令，2 月份有“致同事信”。3 月，一个新的工作组开始调查 DEI 和反犹太主义。
In April, the NIH starts requiring researchers to certify that their colleges do not have any DEI programs. Then in May, the Department of Justice launches a Civil Rights Fraud Initiative. And one of the most dramatic and public interventions the Trump administration has taken on is with a few high-profile, elite schools-- Brown, Harvard, Columbia, and the University of Pennsylvania.
4 月，NIH 开始要求研究人员证明他们的大学没有任何 DEI 项目。然后 5 月，司法部发起了“民权欺诈倡议”。特朗普政府采取的最引人注目和公开的干预措施之一，针对的是一些备受瞩目的精英学校——布朗大学、哈佛大学、哥伦比亚大学和宾夕法尼亚大学。
And that's act two. Act Two, the Art of the Deal. Something we've never really seen before is a presidential administration withholding millions in federal research money from schools it claims are centers of indoctrination and antisemitism. Columbia University was the first school to have one of those showdowns with the administration.
这就是第二幕。第二幕，交易的艺术。我们从未见过总统政府向其宣称是洗脑和反犹太主义中心学校扣留数百万美元联邦研究经费的情况。哥伦比亚大学是第一所与政府发生此类对抗的学校。
It withheld $400 million in federal funding until Columbia agreed to a settlement, one that came with a number of conditions. One of those conditions-- the administration wanted Columbia to more formally incorporate a controversial, government-approved definition of antisemitism. It's known as the International Holocaust Remembrance Alliance working definition, I-H-R-A, or IHRA for short.
它扣留了 4 亿美元的联邦资金，直到哥伦比亚大学同意了一项和解方案，方案附带了许多条件。其中一个条件——政府希望哥伦比亚大学更正式地纳入一个有争议的、政府批准的“反犹太主义”定义。它被称为“国际大屠杀纪念联盟”工作定义，缩写为 IHRA。
The IHRA definition was already one of several definitions Columbia considered when it evaluated claims of antisemitism. But now IHRA was officially incorporated, alongside some new, unprecedented government oversight. Professors at Columbia have been trying to figure out what does the IHRA definition mean for them and their classes this year? Ike Sriskandarajah has been talking to ones who are worried and making plans.
IHRA 的定义已经是哥伦比亚大学评估反犹太主义指控时考虑的几个定义之一。但现在 IHRA 被正式纳入，并伴随着新的、前所未有的政府监管。哥伦比亚大学的教授们一直在试图弄清楚，IHRA 定义对他们和他们今年的课程意味着什么？Ike Sriskandarajah 一直在与那些担心并制定计划的教授交谈。
The definition itself is pretty straightforward. It's about the length of a tweet-- basically, antisemitism is a hatred of Jews, but it comes with 11 examples that expand on that definition. Most are pretty obvious-- calling for the killing of Jews, denying the Holocaust. Those are antisemitic.
定义本身相当简单。也就推文的长度——基本上，反犹太主义是对犹太人的仇恨，但它附带了 11 个扩展定义的例子。大多数都很明显——呼吁杀害犹太人，否认大屠杀。这些都是反犹太主义。
But where it gets tricky are a few examples that blur the line between antisemitism and criticism of the state of Israel. Professors told me that's the part they're worried about. They have to figure out how to teach under this new rule.
但棘手的地方在于有几个例子模糊了反犹太主义和批评以色列国家之间的界限。教授们告诉我，那正是他们担心的地方。他们必须弄清楚在这个新规则下如何教学。
I heard about three different strategies. First are the professors who say they can't teach. Marianne Hirsch canceled her class. She teaches comparative literature and gender studies at Columbia.
我听说了三种不同的策略。首先是那些说没法教了的教授。Marianne Hirsch 取消了她的课。她在哥伦比亚大学教授比较文学和性别研究。
So the course that I've taught before is called Imaging War, Imagining Peace. And it's about images of war from the Armenian Genocide and World War I to the present. Are these images really contesting war, or are they still, in some ways, celebrating war? And how the war of images is always part of war.
我以前教的一门课叫《想象战争，想象和平》。它是关于从亚美尼亚大屠杀和一战到现在的战争影像。这些影像真的是在反对战争，还是在某种程度上仍在颂扬战争？战争的影像本身就是战争的一部分。
One of the IHRA examples on her mind when thinking about her lecture on the first day of class-- example 10, comparing contemporary Israeli policies to that of the Nazis.
她在思考第一堂课的讲义时想到了其中一个 IHRA 的例子——第 10 条：将当代以色列政策与纳粹进行比较。
I didn't see how I could teach this course without teaching about the present day images of the war in Gaza. I thought about how I would structure my first class. And it would have been about what kind of images of war become iconic?
如果不教加沙战争的当代影像，我看不出怎么教这门课。我思考过如何构建我的第一堂课。主题本应是“什么样的战争影像成为标志性的？”
Little boy in the Warsaw ghetto, the so-called napalm girl during the Vietnam War. And putting those images of children in Gaza next to the little boy in the Warsaw ghetto with Nazi soldiers pointing guns at him is implicitly a comparison of IDF soldiers with Nazis.
华沙犹太隔离区里的小男孩，越战期间所谓的“汽油弹女孩”。把加沙儿童的那些影像和华沙隔离区里纳粹士兵用枪指着的小男孩并列在一起，隐喻上就是以色列国防军士兵与纳粹的比较。
Professor Hirsch has dedicated her career to studying the effects of trauma. She's Jewish. And her parents survived the Holocaust. And she's worried about IHRA, partly because in 2023 a student formally accused her of antisemitism.
Hirsch 教授致力于研究创伤效应。她是犹太人。她的父母在大屠杀中幸存下来。她担心 IHRA，部分原因是在 2023 年，一名学生正式指控她反犹太主义。
It was in a class similar to the one she just described. She shared some recent articles related to the war in Gaza that she thought were important. But a student complained, saying they weren't relevant to the class and that some of the reading rationalized acts of antisemitism. The charge against Professor Hirsch was eventually dropped. But she came out of it feeling like she can't run her class the way she wants to. And that was before IHRA. So that's the first thing Columbia professors are doing, dropping their courses.
那是在一门类似于她刚才描述的课上。她分享了一些与加沙战争相关的最新文章，她认为这很重要。但一名学生抱怨说，这与课程无关，而且一些阅读材料将反犹太主义行为合理化了。针对 Hirsch 教授的指控最终被撤销了。但她感觉自己无法按自己的意愿授课。那还是在 IHRA 之前。所以这是哥伦比亚教授们做的第一件事：退课。
One of the best known Palestinian scholars, Rashid Khalidi, withdrew his course on modern Middle East History. The professor said in an open letter, quote, "It is impossible to teach this course and much else in light of Columbia's adoption of the IHRA definition of antisemitism."
最著名的巴勒斯坦学者之一，Rashid Khalidi，退出了他的现代中东史课程。这位教授在一封公开信中写道：“鉴于哥伦比亚大学采用了 IHRA 的反犹太主义定义，教授这门课程以及许多其他内容是不可能的。”
The second thing professors are doing because of IHRA, tweaking what they teach. Professor Najam Haider teaches courses about Islam, including Islam in the postcolonial world. He talks about scholars like other people talk about celebs. And one of his favorites is someone he is now concerned about assigning.
教授们因为 IHRA 而做的第二件事是：调整教学内容。Najam Haider 教授教授有关伊斯兰教的课程，包括后殖民世界的伊斯兰教。他谈论学者就像其他人谈论名人一样。他最喜欢的学者之一是他现在担心分配阅读材料的对象。
Hannah Arendt was very ambivalent about the state of Israel, and she was very critical of Zionism and Zionist organizations during Nazi Germany in the run up to the Holocaust.
汉娜·阿伦特（Hannah Arendt）对以色列国持非常矛盾的态度，她在纳粹德国时期在大屠杀前夕对犹太复国主义和犹太复国主义组织持非常严厉的批评态度。
I gotta say, Hannah Arendt came up in nearly every call, eight times alone in my conversation with Professor Haider. If you haven't read her, don't worry. It's still early in the semester. The CliffsNotes version is she's an influential Jewish journalist and scholar who fled Nazi Germany. She came to America and famously coined the phrase "the banality of evil" to describe the mindset in Germany that led to the Holocaust. Like Professor Hirsch, Professor Haider is also worried about that IHRA example, the one about drawing comparisons to Nazis, which Arendt does.
我必须说，汉娜·阿伦特在几乎每一次通话中都出现了，仅在我和 Haider 教授的谈话中就提到了八次。如果你还没读过她，别担心。学期才刚刚开始。简而言之，她是一位有影响力的犹太记者和学者，逃离了纳粹德国。她来到美国，以“平庸的邪恶”一词闻名，描述了德国导致大屠杀的心态。像 Hirsch 教授一样，Haider 教授也担心那个关于作纳粹比较的 IHRA 例子，阿伦特确实做了这种比较。
Now, how am I supposed to teach Hannah Arendt? Because her critique of the state of Israel and Zionism can then be spun as antisemitism. So instead of me teaching Hannah Arendt, I have to find a way of getting around Hannah Arendt but making the same points. So then I go to Fanon.
现在，我该怎么教汉娜·阿伦特？因为她对以色列国和犹太复国主义的批判会被包装成反犹太主义。所以与其教汉娜·阿伦特，我必须找办法绕过她，但要表达出同样的观点。所以我转而研究法农（Fanon）。
And then I'm talking about Iran. And so what I end up with is a whole class on how Iranian Shi'ism has taken a religious tradition and made it into a political ideology. And if I make that critique of Iran, I can do that comfortably. But if I were to make a similar critique of Israel, it would be antisemitism. And this is what the IHRA definition does. What it does is it creates an exception for Israel, where any critique of Israel is treated differently from a critique of any other modern state.
然后我谈论伊朗。结果我最后上了一整堂关于伊朗什叶派如何将一种宗教传统变成政治意识形态的课。如果我对伊朗进行这种批评，我可以很从容地做到。但如果我对以色列进行类似的批评，那就是反犹太主义。这就是 IHRA 定义的作用。它为以色列制造了一个例外，任何对以色列的批评都被视为与对任何其他现代国家的批评不同。
He's already dropped Hannah Arendt from his syllabus. And Professor Haider says his untenured colleagues are going even further out of their way to avoid controversy.
他已经从教学大纲中删除了汉娜·阿伦特。Haider 教授说，他没有终身教职的同事们更是竭尽全力避免争议。
I've had colleagues in Islamic studies who have said, they used to teach modern topics, and now they're going to go back and only teach classical Islam because they don't think that they're able to teach modern topics anymore. And what that does is it reinscribes orientalism.
我有一些伊斯兰研究的同事说，他们以前教现代课题，现在准备退回去只教古典伊斯兰，因为他们认为自己没法再教现代课题了。这会导致“东方主义”的重现。
Orientalism sounds like the ramen flavor, but it's a kind of racism.
东方主义听起来像方便面口味，但它是一种种族主义。
And one of the premises of Orientalism was this idea that you don't teach Islam as a living tradition. You teach it as something in the past that is ossified. And so what happens when all your classes on Islamic studies now go back to that?
东方主义的前提之一是：不要把伊斯兰教作为一种活生生的传统来教。你要把它作为过去已经僵化的东西来教。所以，如果所有伊斯兰研究课程都变回那样，会发生什么呢？
The third strategy professors are trying is to do nothing. These teachers are not canceling their classes. They're not changing their classes, even though they think the material they teach will be in violation of IHRA, like Professor Thea Abu El-Haj. She's an educational anthropologist who focuses on Palestinians in the diaspora. She's Palestinian, and she's concerned about the ambiguity of the IHRA examples. She wondered if her entire class might violate the IHRA example number 7, denying the Jewish people their right to self-determination by claiming that the existence of the State of Israel is a racist endeavor?
教授们尝试的第三种策略是“什么都不做”。这些老师没有取消课程。他们没有改变课程，尽管他们认为他们教的内容将违反 IHRA，比如 Thea Abu El-Haj 教授。她是一位关注侨民巴勒斯坦人的教育人类学家。她是巴勒斯坦人，她担心 IHRA 例子中的歧义。她怀疑她的整门课是否可能违反了 IHRA 第 7 条例子：否认犹太人民的自决权，声称以色列国的存在是种族主义努力？
(SUBJECT) THEA ABU EL-HAJ: I mean, there is no Palestinian scholarship that is not questioning the settler colonial nature of the state. How do I teach the 2018 Nationalities Law, which states that only Jews have the right to self-determination in the state of Israel? Can I teach that? Can I teach Amnesty's apartheid report?
Thea Abu El-Haj：我的意思是，没有哪项巴勒斯坦学术研究是不质疑该国定居者殖民性质的。我怎么教 2018 年的《民族国家法》，该法规定只有犹太人在以色列国有权自决？我可以教那个吗？我可以教大赦国际的种族隔离报告吗？
Your answer is, yes.
你的回答是：可以。
(SUBJECT) THEA ABU EL-HAJ: My answer is I have-- if I'm to teach the things I know about and I'm an expert on, I have to be able to teach those things.
Thea Abu El-Haj：我的回答是：如果我要教授我所了解、且我是该领域专家的东西，我就必须能够教授这些。
Her sister, Nadia Abu El-Haj, is also a professor at Columbia. She teaches an anthropology of war class and directs the Center for Palestine Studies. And she says she's not considering revising anything for IHRA, not in her class, not in events at the center.
她的妹妹 Nadia Abu El-Haj 也是哥伦比亚大学的教授。她教授战争人类学课程，并指导巴勒斯坦研究中心。她说她没有考虑为 IHRA 修改任何东西，在她的课上，在中心举办的活动中都不会。
(SUBJECT) NADIA ABU EL-HAJ: So I get the choice we have is, do we dance around it? Or do we just take it head on? And this is my work. And there's nothing I-- I mean, we could either close the Center of Palestine Studies, or we can just take it head on and see what happens.
Nadia Abu El-Haj：我们面临的选择是，我们绕着它走？还是正面硬刚？这是我的工作。除了关闭巴勒斯坦研究中心，或者正面硬刚看看会发生什么，我别无选择。
And your thought on this is the latter?
你对此的思考是后者？
(SUBJECT) NADIA ABU EL-HAJ: Oh, absolutely. This has been my work for over 20 years. So this is so central to what I do that I feel like you want to fire me, fire me. I mean, I'm not going to cave.
Nadia Abu El-Haj：噢，当然。这已经是我 20 多年的工作了。这太核心了，所以我感觉，你们想解雇我，就解雇我吧。我不会屈服。
She's already gamed out in her head how the consequences will unfold.
她已经在脑海里推演过后果会如何展开。
(SUBJECT) NADIA ABU EL-HAJ: There'll be a student in class. You'll assign a book. They'll say, this is discriminatory. Now, the accumulation of those charges of discrimination, ultimately, they can fire you. It's never been used that way before, but it's going to be used, and it's going to be the same thing with public events at the center. Someone will come to an event. They will launch a complaint against the center for antisemitism and we'll be in this cycle.
Nadia Abu El-Haj：课堂上会有一个学生。你布置一本书。他们会说，这是歧视性的。现在，这些歧视指控的积累，最终，他们可以解雇你。以前从来没有这样用过，但它会被用起来，公共中心举办的活动也会发生同样的事。有人会来参加活动。他们会以反犹太主义为由对中心发起投诉，我们将陷入这种循环。
She's a tenured professor who, theoretically, they can't fire except in the most extreme circumstances.
她是终身教授，理论上，除非在最极端的情况下，否则他们不能解雇她。
Do you think you have a job this time next year?
你觉得明年这个时候你还有这份工作吗？
(SUBJECT) NADIA ABU EL-HAJ: I think it'd take a while to fire me, but I don't think it's off the table. [LAUGHS] I mean, honestly, I have no idea.
Nadia Abu El-Haj：我觉得解雇我需要一点时间，但我认为这并非不可能。[笑声] 我的意思是，老实说，我不知道。
She has no idea. And all these professors, they're just guessing because Columbia did not just agree to the IHRA definition. Columbia agreed to have a monitor, a person who'd watch over everything that Columbia said it would do under its settlement with the government.
她确实不知道。所有这些教授都在猜测，因为哥伦比亚大学不仅同意了 IHRA 的定义。哥伦比亚大学还同意设一名“监督员”，一个监视哥伦比亚大学根据与政府的和解协议所承诺的一切的人。
But what will the monitor do? What's his budget? How many people can he hire? It's unclear. Columbia says the monitor does not have oversight over academic content or curriculum. But when I read the terms of the agreement, it says the monitor will have access to, quote, "all agreement-related individuals, facilities, disciplinary hearings, and the scene of any occurrence that the monitor deems necessary," also, quote, "all documents and data related to the agreement." That seems like a lot of stuff.
但这名监督员要做什么？他的预算是多少？他能雇多少人？不清楚。哥伦比亚大学表示，监督员对学术内容或课程没有监督权。但当我阅读协议条款时，它写着监督员将有权访问，引用：“所有与协议相关的个人、设施、纪律听证会，以及监督员认为必要的任何事件现场”，以及引用：“所有与协议相关的文件和数据”。那看起来涉及很多东西。
The monitor, Bart Schwartz, declined to answer our questions. Najam Haider, the religion professor, told me he's been asking his bosses, is this monitor going to be reviewing what I teach?
监督员 Bart Schwartz 拒绝回答我们的问题。宗教教授 Najam Haider 告诉我，他一直在问老板，这位监督员会审查我教的内容吗？
When this was brought up with Columbia administration, they said, oh, don't worry about it. But they always just say, don't worry about it. They don't tell you they're not going to be able to do that.
当这被带到哥伦比亚行政部门时，他们说，噢，不用担心。但他们总是只说“不用担心”。他们不会告诉你他们不会那样做。
If you ask them a question, and you say, can this person sit in on my classroom, can they just walk in? They're going to be like, we don't think that's going to happen. They're not going to say, no, they can't. There are no limits that have been set to the degree to which they have access to teaching at Columbia.
如果你问他们一个问题，说这个人能坐进我的教室吗，他能直接走进来吗？他们会像说“我们认为那不会发生”。他们不会说“不，他不能”。对于他们访问哥伦比亚教学权限的程度，没有设任何限制。
Were there limits before?
以前有限制吗？
There would be no monitor. There's no monitors before. There's no one doing this work.
以前没有监督员。以前没有监督员。没有人在做这份工作。
I did talk to one faculty member who falls into none of these three categories when it comes to the IHRA definition. She's in a category that I call, no big deal. And she comes to that conclusion based on the job that she's had on campus the last two years as co-chair of Columbia's Task Force on Antisemitism, Professor Ester Fuchs.
我确实采访过一位教职员工，在 IHRA 定义方面，她不属于这三类中的任何一类。她属于我称之为“没啥大不了”的一类。她得出这个结论是基于过去两年她在校园里的工作，她是哥伦比亚大学反犹太主义工作组的联合主席，Ester Fuchs 教授。
She didn't think the school should formally use IHRA. The task force had a different definition of antisemitism that they recommended. She doesn't like how the government is using antisemitism as a weapon to bully college campuses into all sorts of changes. But unlike her colleagues, she doesn't think IHRA is that big a deal.
她不认为学校应该正式使用 IHRA。工作组有一个他们建议的不同反犹太主义定义。她不喜欢政府如何利用反犹太主义作为武器来欺凌大学校园，强迫其进行各种改革。但与她的同事不同，她不认为 IHRA 是什么大事。
I certainly don't want to give the impression that I believe this is simple. Of course, it's difficult, and I understand why people are frustrated. And I understand why there's differences of opinions. But I don't believe the Trump administration is going to be coming in and monitoring this level of detail at all. And it was very clear in the original agreement there is no involvement of the federal government in curriculum, in admissions, or in faculty hiring.
我当然不想给人一种我认为这很简单错觉。当然，这很困难，我理解为什么人们感到沮丧。我也理解为什么会有不同的意见。但我认为特朗普政府根本不会进来监控这种程度的细节。最初的协议非常明确，联邦政府不参与课程、招生或教师聘用。
The agreement does explicitly say the government won't, quote, "Dictate faculty hiring, university hiring, admissions decisions, or the content of academic speech." But the agreement also gives the government broad oversight over academic departments, complaints of antisemitism, and admissions. And the agreement requires a review of educational programs to ensure they are, quote, "comprehensive and balanced."
该协议确实明确表示，政府不会引用：“指定教师聘用、大学招聘、招生决定或学术言论的内容。”但该协议也赋予了政府对学术部门、反犹太主义投诉和招生的广泛监管权。该协议要求审查教育项目，以确保它们是，引用：“全面且平衡的”。
So you can read it Professor Fuch's way, or you can read it the way the other professors I talked to read it. But let me just say this, for Professor Fuchs, the conclusion is unambiguous-- there's nothing to be scared of.
所以你可以用 Fuchs 教授的方式阅读它，或者用我采访的其他教授的方式阅读它。但让我这么说吧，对于 Fuchs 教授来说，结论是明确的——没什么好怕的。
I mean, people do your job, for god's sake. Instead of making students nervous, getting everybody upset, do your job. Figure it out. That's what we're supposed to be doing. Everybody turned themselves into martyrs here. What a bad joke.
我的意思是，人们做你们的工作吧，看在上帝的份上。与其让学生紧张，让每个人心烦意乱，不如做你们的工作。把问题搞定。这才是我们应该做的。每个人都把自己变成了烈士。这真是个糟糕的笑话。
So what is going to happen this year? Which way is this going to go? I read the agreement between the government and Columbia again last night. It's sprawling. For a battle that started over antisemitism, the document also covers trans students in locker rooms and international students and admissions and DEI.
那么今年会发生什么？这会走向何方？昨晚我又读了一遍政府和哥伦比亚大学之间的协议。它覆盖面很广。对于一场围绕反犹太主义开始的战斗，这份文件还涵盖了更衣室里的跨性别学生、国际学生、招生和 DEI。
And what the agreement does is it lets the Trump administration crack down on any of that if it decides the University is out of line. Maybe it'll choose IHRA, maybe it'll choose something else. Between the withholding of hundreds of millions of dollars, IHRA, the monitor, this administration has given themselves a new set of tools to transform higher ed.
而这份协议的作用是，它让特朗普政府能够在这其中任何一项上采取严厉打击行动，如果它判定大学越界的话。也许它会选择 IHRA，也许它会选择别的。扣留数亿美元资金、IHRA、监督员，这届政府给了自己一套新的工具来改造高等教育。
Ike Sriskandarajah is a producer on our show.
Ike Sriskandarajah 是我们节目的制片人。
Our program was produced by Miki Meek and Emannuel Dzotsi. It was edited by Chana Joffe-Walt. People who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Zoe Chace, Michael Comite, Suzanne Gaber, Sophie Gill, Valerie Kipnis, Katherine Rae Mando, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor Sarah Abdurrahman, and our senior editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目由 Miki Meek 和 Emmanuel Dzotsi 制作。由 Chana Joffe-Walt 编辑。今天参与制作节目的人包括 Phia Bennin、Zoe Chace、Michael Comite、Suzanne Gaber、Sophie Gill、Valerie Kipnis、Katherine Rae Mando、Stowe Nelson、Nadia Reiman、Anthony Roman、Ryan Rumery、Frances Swanson、Christopher Swetala、Marisa Robertson-Textor、Nancy Updike、Julie Whitaker 和 Diane Wu。我们的执行编辑是 Sarah Abdurrahman，高级编辑是 David Kestenbaum。
Special thanks to Meligha Garfield, Sandrine Mimche, Sadie Werner, Kathryn Bond Stockton, Alex Tokita, Karen Kwan, Bilal Kuchay, Mariya Karimjee, Mike Gavin, Azmat Khan, Maryam Alwan, Cameron Jones, Yoni Kurtz, Allie Arcese, Melanie Storey, Tennessee Watson, Madelyn Beck, Kenneth Stern, Noah Lederman, Xavier Westergaard, Chrystal Bell, and Maya Perkins.
特别感谢 Meligha Garfield、Sandrine Mimche、Sadie Werner、Kathryn Bond Stockton、Alex Tokita、Karen Kwan、Bilal Kuchay、Mariya Karimjee、Mike Gavin、Azmat Khan、Maryam Alwan、Cameron Jones、Yoni Kurtz、Allie Arcese、Melanie Storey、Tennessee Watson、Madelyn Beck、Kenneth Stern、Noah Lederman、Xavier Westergaard、Chrystal Bell 和 Maya Perkins。
Special thanks as well to the Office of International Student Services and the Office of International Studies and Programs at Michigan State University, and Arno Rosenfeld, who writes the newsletter Antisemitism Decoded at The Forward.
特别感谢密歇根州立大学国际学生服务办公室和国际研究与项目办公室，以及在《前进报》（The Forward）撰写《反犹太主义解码》简报的 Arno Rosenfeld。
Thanks also to our This American Life Partners. Sign up as a Life Partner and you'll get ad-free listening, a greatest hits archive right in your podcast feed, plus regular exclusive bonus episodes, including dozens that we've already released. Join us at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
也感谢我们的《美国生活》合作伙伴。注册成为生活合作伙伴（Life Partner），您将获得无广告收听、播客订阅源中的经典档案，以及定期的独家奖励剧集，包括我们已经发布的几十集。请在 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners 加入我们。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）提供给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass, who is off this week doing his side hustle, as a personal assistant for Harry and Meghan. One of his most important duties is the wake up call. For old time's sake, he likes to do it this way.
照常感谢我的老板 Ira Glass，他这周请假去搞副业了，担任哈里和梅根的私人助理。他最重要的职责之一是叫醒服务。为了旧情，他喜欢这样做。
Good morning, Royals!
早上好，Royals！
I'm Emanuele Berry. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是 Emanuele Berry。Ira Glass 下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。